anger and frustration boiling over in
Lebanon's capital Beirut security forces
fire tear gas and water cannon on crowds
demanding the government resigns these
protesters say they can't take any more
that years of economic failure have left
them struggling to survive at the end of
the day if I stay hidden behind social
media and I don't go out onto the
streets how can I dare ask for my rights
where do I start
first of all I want to fight corruption
I want to ask those in charge why do you
have this you are living at this level
and I'm running after bread
the crowds marched on Parliament angry
over proposed taxes on tobacco and
petrol the backlash has already forced
the government to scrap plans to charge
users of the messaging service whatsapp
all part of next year's budget as
politicians look for ways to reduce its
mess of debt the third highest in the
world and secured 11 billion dollars in
foreign aid we are staying on the
streets we will come out tomorrow and
after that we are not here over what set
we are here over fuel food bread over
everything protesters blocked roads
across the country including Sudan
Tripoli and the Bekaa Valley we don't
have enough to eat anymore why are you
making us pay more while you sit in your
positions not caring the people are
dying we want our rights we won't leave
the streets before we take our rights
that's it
years of political turmoil and influx of
Syrian refugees and its crumbling
infrastructure are catching up with
Lebanon sky mermans last month banks
rationed foreign currency and a state of
economic emergency was declared with the
unrest leaving schools and universities
closed on Friday the government could
now be facing another kind of emergency
altogether Alexey O'Brien al-jazeera